تغييرات عديده اجراها ماسك في تويتر منذ
ان اشترى هذه الشركه في عام
2022 اخرها اعلان عن خطه لتطهير حسابات
تويتر القديمه التي ليس لها اي نشاط منذ
سنه بالفعل الملياردير ماسك قل في تغريدته
سنطهر الحسابات التي لم يكن لها اي نشاط
خلال السنوات العديده الماضيه لذا من
المحتمل ان نشهد انخفاضا في عدد المتابعين
اعلان ماسك هذا قبل برد فعل عنيف اذ عبر
العديد من المستخدمين في الشبكه
الاجتماعيه عن قلقهم من الخطوه اذا ما
سيحل ماذا سيحل بحسابات الاشخاص الذين
ماتوا مثلا مشيرين الى ان حذف حسابات
احبابهم هو اشبه بازاله شاهد القبر يعتقد
ايضا ان الخطوه الجديده من تويتر في تطهير
الحسابات القديمه قد تصب في صالح مساعي
ماسكي الى زياده ايرادات تويتر خاصه بعد
ان افادت صحيفه
تنظر في بيع اثناء المستخدمين لجني
ايرادات جديده المزيد حول هذا طبعا الجدل
جدل تويتر مع الزميله هند ابراهيم من وين
من واشنطن هند
[موسيقى]
كانت تغريدات تويتر تنهمر مثل المطر غزيره
ومن كل اتجاه وكانت المظله التي تحمينا من
المعلومات المغلوطه هي علامه التحقق
الزرقاء لكن هذه العلامه اصبحت بقياده
ايلان ماسك رمزا للعار حتى ان بعض الشركات
رفضت استخدامها رغم ان ماسك قدمها لها
مجانا
[موسيقى]
منذ ان استلم الملياردير ماسك شركه تويتر
وهي في تغيير مستمر تاركه للمشتركين في
حيره ازاء مصير حساباتهم علامه التحقق
التي تم اطلاقها عام 2009 اختفت من حسابات
نشطاء وعلماء وصحفيين لم يدفعوا الرسوم
الشهريه بينما وثقت العلامه الزرقاء صفحات
شخصيات غير معروفه تدفع الرسوم
ظهور واختفاء العلامه الزرقاء من عده
حسابات خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
المستخدمين فقد استعادت الحسابات الكبرى
اي التي لديها اكثر من مليون مستخدم
العلامه الزرقاء بينما قال ماسك انه دفع
رسوم بعض المشاهير للحفاظ على علاماتهم
وقد تختفي العلامه لبضعه ايام اذا تم
تغيير الصوره الشخصيه لكنها تعود للحسابات
المدفوعه بعد التاكد وتنعم هذه الحسابات
بميزات خاصه اذ يمكن لتغريداتهم ان تكون
اطول والدعايات التي تظهر لهم اقل بنسبه
50%
[موسيقى]
علامه التحقق الزرقاء التي باتت من حق
الحسابات المدفوعه سواء لاشخاص او شركات
لا تعني اي شيء غير ان الحساب لمشترك في
المنصه وتم التحقق من رقم هاتفه
[موسيقى]
فهل سيتغير نشاط المنصه مع الوقت من تفاعل
وتغريد من قبل المستخدمين وهل سيقبل البعض
استعاده علاماتهم الزرق بالمال هذا ما
ستكشفه لنا الايام لصباح العربيه هند
ابراهيم واشنطن
[موسيقى]
نحن سالنا ناس في السعوديه هل ستدفع لتوثق
حسابك على تويتر بالاجابه سلام
[موسيقى]
والله انا صراحه
التوثيق ما له علاقه بالدفع ارى لا يكون
في دفع في التوثيق يعني
والله ماني مهتم لتوثيق وكذا
ما واثق حسابي وكذا صراحه انا شخص يعني
انا ادخل تويتر برنامج تويتر كثير بس ما
يعني ماني مهتم اني ادفع فلوس عشان
التوثيق والله اذا كان عندي محتوى ما راح
ادفع اكيد اذا ما عندي محتوى بدفع
يعني ما عندكم محتوى تبغى حسابك وعندك
قدره ماليه اكيد متوثق حسابك عن طريق
القدره الماليه
[موسيقى]
ليش ادفع علشان اوثق حسابي
المفترض اني ما ادفعه لا انا متابع في
تويتر وليس ادفع في ناس يدفعون
عشان يصير محتواها من اكثر لاكثر انا
انسان متابع بس لا الصراحه
يعني ما احس انه شيء حلو وغير كذا انه انا
قاعده اشوف اللي يسوى واللي ما يسوى قاعد
يوثق حسابه
احس انه بس تجميع متابعيني على الفاضي
[موسيقى]
معنا على مشاهدينا من ابها ابراهيم جمال
الدين استشاري التسويق والتواصل اهلا بك
يا ابراهيم معنا في صباح الخير
انت راح تدفع ابراهيم
انا كنت وددت يعني ابدا بهذا الموضوع انه
واضح انه كتير ناس او ثلاث ارباع الناس
متفقين على انه ما راح يدفعوا فبالتالي
حركه ماسك بانه فرض اموال على علامه
التوثيق هاي اعتقد انه خلت هاي العلامه
بلا قيمه الان
بالضبط كده والدليل هو رد فعل المتابعين
ورد فعل للبعض ممن كان حساباتهم قبل كده
موثقه من الصحفيين او الشخصيات العامه
اللي خدوا موقف مبدئي مش بدفع المادي ولكن
انه حسين انه انا ليه اقدر ان انا اتواصل
مع الناس بمحتوياه بمكانتي فيلم مجتمع
الحقيقيه واللي كانت علامه التنسيق بتدلل
على ده في حين انها تقدر تحقق ده من مجرد
اشتراك ب 8 دولار في الشهر طيب يعني
ابراهيم هل تعتقد انه ماسك فقط هم
الثمانيه دولار اللي حيدفعها فلان ابراهيم
ولا عادل ولا غيره ولا راويه ولا انه
الموضوع ابعد من ذلك
احنا بنشرح من حالات الفوضى بصراحه في
اداره تويتر من ساعه الى الماسك ما استحو
على المنصه فكره الثمانيه دولار بتعود
بالاساس لتنويع مصادر الدخل للمنصه وقلت
اتفضل
كانت الفكره منه ورا الاشتراكات المدفوعه
الاجر انه تنويع مصادر الدخل للمنصه خصوصا
مع
تذبذب حركه الاسهم في شركه تويتر فكره انه
لو عندي فرصه بالنسبه لو عنده فرصه انه
يدر دخل اضافي من ورا الموضوع لما لا
طيب يعني هو واضح بانه كانت يعني هاي
الخطوه مبنيه على قرار اقتصادي بحث ولكن
في عالم اداره الاعمال وحتى خصوصا في
شركات التكنولوجيا سمعه الشركه لها قيمه
لا تقدر بثمن فهل معقول بانه يعني لا يتم
التراجع عن قرار اقتصادي هدفه كان منفعه
الشركه اذا النتيجه كانت العكس وهي
الاضرار بالشركه عن طريق الاضرار بسمعتها
يعني كثير ناس الان بطلوا ينظروا لتويتر
بنفس الطريقه اللي كان ينظروا لها زمان
رقيق ولكن هنا بتيجي فكره القرارات الضخمه
من النوع ده في اداره منصات ضخمه بالشكل
ده فكره انه يتم التراجع عن هذا القرار
اظن هتبقى صعبه جدا بل مستحيله لان حجم
البشر اللي بيتم التحكم في قرار زائده
بنتكلم على حوالي 300 الف حساب كانوا
موفقين 15% منهم بس وفي تقديرات بتكون 5%
بس من الحسابات
ان هي تدفع لهذا الاشتراك والباقي احجم عن
هذا الامر بس في ناس مستمره يا ابراهيم
يعني البعض قد يقبلها من انه الشركات تدفع
ولكن الافراد لا لكن رغم ذلك تويتر يبقى
منصه مهمه
الشركات ممكن افهمها الافراد الموضوع اصبح
في تحدي اكبر بكتير الشركات طول عمرها
تقدر ان هي توثق هويتها حتى لو واجهت بعض
التحديات في ده ولكن الشخصيات العامه او
شخصيه خصوصا فيما له علاقه بالامور
السياسيه الامور الاقتصاديه صحفيين الناس
اللي كان لهم حق التوثيق حساباتهم بشكل
خاص اصبح الموضوع سحب هذه المصداقيه منهم
واتاحتها للافراد جميعا مما يملكون هذا
الحق فبالتالي الافراد
ذول حيثيه هم اللي لهم الحيثيه فكره اتاحه
الاشتراك بالاموال اظهر عدد من المؤثرين
الجدد اللي بيحاولوا يعيدوا تقديم نفسهم
على المنصه باعتبارهم اشخاص ذوي حيثيه
بيقدموا محتوى قيمه فهناك مستفيدين من هذا
الامر
وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات